افاد مراسل الجزيره باستمرار القتال بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طرفي نهر
دنبرو في خرسون جنوب اوكرانيا وقال ان
دويا في جارات متواصل يصنع بكثافه في
خيرسون التي انسحب منها الروس اخيرا اتقول
القوه الاوكرانيه انها تقصف بالمدفعيه
مواقع مركز الجيش الروسي من الجهه اليمنى
من النهر معنا من ميكو ضعيف مراسل الجزيره
ماضي تامر اهلا بك ضعنا في الصوره
مدينه خيرسون نستطيع القول بان المواجهه
مستعيره بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات
الروسيه على طرفي نهر الدنبر الذي يفصل
مدينه خيرسون هذه المدينه التي سحبت منها
القوات الروسيه قبل نحو اسبوعين من الان
القتال يجري بالمدفعيه المدفعيه الثقيله
بين الطرفين ونحن في قلب المدينه التي
تفتقد الى كاف كامل الامكانيات في الحقيقه
المعيشيه في هذه الاثناء كنا نستمع الى
صوت همم مكثف للقصف بين الطرفين حاولنا
الوصول الى ضفه نهر الدنبر من الجهه
اليسرى التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني
لكن للاسف منعنع من الوصول الى تلك نقطه
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وذلك بسبب
الاجراءات الامنيه والعسكريه المشدده
وبسبب ايضا استعاره المعارك هناك لكن
في السهوله كان يمكننا ان نرصد اعمده
الدخان المتساعده من اكثر من مكان همم في
على ضفتينها دينيبر بين الطرفين القوات
الاوكرانيه قالت بانها كثفت من قصفها
لاماكن تواجد وتمركز القوات الروسيه على
الجهه اليمنى من النهر وقالت بانها
تمكنت من يعني تدمير همم العديد من العتاد
للقوات الروسيه وتحدثت عن قتلى وجرح صباح
هذا اليوم اشارت ايضا الى تدمير مركز
للقياده والسيطره الروسيه هنالك عندما
نتحدث ايضا بعيدا عن التطورات الميدانيه
العسكريه نتحدث عن التطورات الانسانيه
هنالك حاله مزريه في الحقيقه داخل المدينه
خير سول لا يوجد كهرباء حتى هذه اللحظه لا
ما لا غذاء للناس لمن تبقى اصلا من سكان
هنالك القوات
الاوكرانيه قامت بنصب مجموعه كبيره من
الخيام في قلب المدينه لاستقبال من تبقى
هنالك من سكان واثر لهم خدمه الاتصال من
خلال مولدات كهربائيه بالاضافه الى همم
يعني الاغذيه وقليل من المياه التي توفرها
من خلال همم خاصه بها لكن في الحقيقه
تطورات ايضا متسارعه بعيدا عن خيرسون في
عموم المناطق الجنوبيه
الكولايف الليله الماضيه غرقت في الظلام
بسبب ضربات الجويه الروسيه كما قالت
القوات الاوكرانيه للبونيه التحتيه
الحيويه وكان هنالك اطلاق للدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه في قلب المدينه وذلك
لاستهداف او لصد صواريخ كما قالت او قال
عمده مدينه نيكولايب صواريخ روسيه لكن لم
يصب احد باذى الليله الماضيه نتيجه هذه
الصواريخ هنا في ميكو لايف لكن ايضا
التطورات متلاحقه ومتلاحقه جدا في همم
زاباروجيا زباروجا تقول لها السلطات
الاوكرانيه بان العديد من القرى في تلك
المدينه تتعرض لقصف متواصل من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه الحديث عن اكثر من 20 قريه في
زبرجه تتعرض للقصف لليوم الثالث على
التوالي والحديث عن عشرات المنازل التي
دمرت بالفعل هناك وعندما نتحدث عن زبرج
همم يعني نتحدث ايضا عن الكوبل هذه
المدينه الواقعه بين زبروجيا
ودينيبرو وسط جنوبيه البلاد وهي القريبه
من المفاعل النووي في زب- او عفوا المحطه
النوويه محطه الطاقه النوويه في سباروجا
هذه المدينه تتعرض لقصف متواصل وشديد جدا
ايضا منذ ايام وصباح هذا اليوم تحدثت
السلطات هنالك عن ذات الشيء ونهايه همم
تطورات بالقرب من هناك من كريفيري هيتقاله
السلطات بانها تمكنت صباح اليوم من انقاذ
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف عامل في المناجم همم
كانوا تحت الارض بسبب انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي في المدينه مدينه ريفرينان